unemployment rates and employment
catastrophe of unemployment unemployment
fear of unemployment unemployment
something we hear a lot about
unemployment rates unemployment rate
unemployment unemployment rate it's in
the news politicians are always talking
about it unemployment rate unemployment
rate unemployment unemployment
unemployment rate basically whenever we
talk about the economy unemployment is a
part of the conversation but it seems
kind of simple right like isn't it just
a measure of how many people can't find
jobs so why have I decided to make an
entire video about it well because
behind this definition there was
something much bigger going on something
that teaches us about the inner workings
of the economy unemployment remains a a
serious problem unemployment is where
the cold rational mechanics of Economics
meets the aspirations and
disappointments of millions of people
and it shows us how our capitalistic
system can succeed and fail in
allocating the most important of its
resources its people unemployment
unemployment unemployment the
unemployment rate unemployment it's okay
I got options unemployment financial
crisis
looks good
cool let's go so we hear this word
economy all the time but what exactly is
an economy think of the economy as a set
of rules relationships and patterns that
help huge groups of people that don't
know each other somehow peacefully
coordinate with one another all of this
with the aim of allocating scarce
resources in an efficient way that
theoretically should benefit everyone we
all live and participate in an economy
that somehow mostly Works somehow all of
us billions of people manage to
coordinate with each other to produce to
innovate to push the productive
boundaries of society forward but none
of this complex coordination would be
possible without one key ingredient it's
the number that you see everywhere you
go this key ingredient is prices
[Music]
are not just prices like it's not just
the number depending on how much it
costs prices are like telephone wires in
the economy they're like the lighthouse
that sends out a signal to make the
whole thing work anyone who didn't study
economics is like wait it's just prices
why why are you calling it a lighthouse
when I was studying econ this prices are
a signal thing was really hard to get my
head around but I now understand that
prices are the glue of the economy the
mechanism through which the market
organizes itself so that millions of
people can make billions of decisions in
a harmonious way to see what I mean and
to figure out what this has to do with
unemployment which is why you clicked on
this video let's go back to the
neighborhood that helped us understand
what a recession is in our last econ
video that we make yes I make macro
economic videos now because the people
seem to like it and I seem to like it so
we're all happy and let's once again
focus on baguettes because I like french
bread and I lament the fact that my
country doesn't have enough of it
do you yeah
yeah how do you coincidentally you have
a baguette in this PL in this studio
right now yeah it's in my kitchen
not only do you have animation you have
a real baguette that I may nipple on
throughout this video
okay
let's go to the neighborhood okay so
we're in this neighborhood and baguettes
are actually becoming a cool thing
they're trending everyone's talking
about baguettes and this one Bakery is
pumping out delicious Artisan baguettes
for your neighborhood these baguettes
are like three dollars a piece which is
a nice affordable price more and more
people are showing up to buy them but
the bakery has a problem they only have
capacity to make 20 baguettes per day
but because baguettes are trending 30
people want to buy baguettes at three
dollars a piece so what does the baker
do to fix this I know says the baker
let's raise prices the baker realizes
that because of all this demand they can
raise prices from three dollars to four
dollars and that's exactly what he does
and boom they just sent out a signal to
the entire neighborhood baguettes are
trending in the neighborhood the baker
thinks that people are willing to pay
four dollars of the 30 people who were
in line to buy the baguettes back when
they were three dollars ten of them
shake their head they're like no way
Jose four dollars is way too spendy for
a baguette these 10 neighbors either
can't afford or are not willing to pay
four bucks for a baguette but look 20 of
them are either fancy rich people or
just really love baguettes and they're
willing to stay in that line to pay four
bucks for their baguettes oh and look
remember that the baker is only able to
make exactly 20 baguettes to meet the 20
baguettes demanded by the people who are
willing to pay four dollars prices did
that I mean in reality the baker didn't
raise prices just so that he could
create a nice equilibrium between supply
and demand he did it because he saw an
opportunity to make more money but in
the process he found a price that
matched his 20 baguettes to 20 people
who were willing to buy them nothing
goes to waste everyone is happy and the
invisible hand has done its work thank
you Adam Smith now inevitably some
entrepreneur is going to show up and be
like oh there's a profit making
opportunity in this neighborhood they're
going to open a bakery and now the
bakery is making like 50 baguettes and
competing with the other Bakery and both
these bakeries will eventually have to
lower their prices so that more people
can get in on these baguettes so they
can get rid of all their baguettes and
baguettes eventually will stabilize to
2.50 or three bucks and now the prices
have been stabilized thank you
competition
for keeping prices low my point in
talking over supply and demand here is
so that when you see the little price
tag on like a box of cereal in the
grocery store just know that this isn't
the company just throwing out a random
number that number in a sense has been
decided for the company by the magic of
the economy that pushes prices to be
just where they need to be to connect
all the stuff available to the number of
people who are willing to pay for it
there's all sorts of caveats to this
prices can sometimes create really bad
outcomes for people what I'm trying to
convey here is that prices are the
language that businesses use to
communicate with consumers a signal that
conveys information and makes it
possible for billions of people to
organize and trade with each other thank
you prices thank you Market speaking of
prices and markets I'm a small business
owner and you might be too and so I'm
going to take a moment to thank our
sponsor which is stamps.com a company
I've been using for years to run my
small business for years I would go to
the post office which is something I
really don't like to do it's a very
inefficient place I finally actually was
watching an ad like this and clicked the
link somewhere and signed up for
stamps.com and it changed my world I'm
saying this very authentically
stamps.com allows you to print your own
Postage and shipping labels from your
office oh but how are we supposed to
know how heavy the package is because
that affects the postage check this out
in our office we have one they give you
a scale you have a scale you measure it
it goes right into your computer and now
you're printing your shipping label and
it comes with a discount on postage from
USPS so it's cheaper and it's very easy
and quick to set up there's a reason why
stamps.com has been around for 25 years
helping small businesses solve the pain
point of shipping things there's a link
in my description stamps.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also gets you in on
one month of freestamps.com a trial
where you can try this out you also get
free postage and a free scale like
they'll send you the scale again I got
in on this deal from like another
YouTuber a few years ago and I haven't
gone back thank you stamps.com for
sponsoring today's video supporting this
channel let's get back to unemployment
the market works because of prices okay
so what happens when you apply the same
Market logic not just to baguettes and
cereal but to the most important
resource of all the people in economics
we call the people labor we are all just
labor instead of prices we call it wages
like how much you get paid for your
labor but the dynamic is really similar
when companies in an economy need
workers with certain skills they go
shopping for labor by posting a job and
deciding how much they are willing to
pay for that job in the form of wages
okay so now we're in a market and once
again prices or wages help match up jobs
demanded by the job Hunters with jobs
supplied by the companies looking for
labor if a company has a lot of money or
really needs workers they can offer a
high wage like back in our neighborhood
where baguettes are trending and the
baker is making great profits and they
need help making more baguettes who's
willing to pay really well and he
quickly attracts people with the right
skills and the job is filled prices or
wages have once again served as a great
Matchmaker in the economy and thanks to
to this labor market Dynamic more high
quality baguettes will be produced with
the energy and talent of different
people the productive frontiers of the
economy are pushed forward people have
jobs the economy is growing okay wait
let's just look at real life for a
second I love the animated world it's
beautiful but like the labor market
Works in real life and it's kind of nuts
like have you ever wondered how on Earth
you can walk into like a pharmacy and
there will be people behind the counter
who have exactly the special training
needed to be there not just in one
Pharmacy but in every Pharmacy in your
city every Pharmacy in the country all
of these people were somehow physically
distributed throughout the whole country
to meet the demand for pharmacists in
order for these pharmacists to end up at
all of these different pharmacies they
had to spend years studying and training
and then they had to take the job and
potentially move to a new place to start
working there and no one overtly told
them to do this like years ago they
decided they wanted to study to be a
pharmacist and then they eventually
graduated and they found a job and maybe
they had to move across the country and
that's one person's Journey now times
that by every pharmacist in every
Pharmacy and now times that by every
architect and doctor and engineer an
x-ray technician and molecular biologist
and speech pathologists and school
teacher and police officer and somehow
human beings are being distributed like
baguettes how on Earth does that happen
thanks to markets and prices and that's
the moral of the story humans are
basically like baguettes who get
allocated throughout the Economy based
on price signals allowing for a perfect
pairing of people and jobs and not a
single person can't find a job womp womp
womp not so fast free market free market
economics does miraculously work quite
well to get people paired up with jobs
all over this country and world but no
people are not baguettes they can't just
be quickly allocated around based on the
economy's needs sometimes the market
fails us and when it does we have
unemployment you had about six million
people in the country unemployed now you
have 12 million people in the country
unemployed people are complex we have
different talents dreams aspirations and
the jobs we take are some of the biggest
decisions of our lives there are way
more factors at play than just how much
the job pays the vastness of Human
Experience doesn't always coordinate
perfectly with the immediate needs of a
market which only cares about
efficiently allocating a scarce resource
and this gets to one really important
version of unemployment economists call
this natural unemployment it's an
acknowledgment that even in the best of
times there will always be certain job
Seekers who aren't working because they
had to go back and get certain training
or they have skills that are no longer
super relevant to the economy so they
have to Pivot or in a lot of cases they
aren't willing to move across the
country far away from family to take a
job that pays well but maybe doesn't
align with their values or whatever
meaning it happens because humans are
just being complex humans making
important decisions and the result is
that some portion of the population will
not be able to find a job productive
resources of the economy sit idle and we
have unemployment natural unemployment
here's what the U.S natural employment
over the last 70 years has looked like
sort of hovers between four to seven
percent which means that at any given
point somewhere between six and seven
million people want a job but can't find
one just because because the economy is
always changing and the skills that are
needed are always changing and humans
are complicated and not baguettes and
finding new jobs is a big deal that's
natural unemployment and it's the one
that you never hear about no one cares
about it it is natural it is a part of
our economy we kind of forget about it
the type of unemployment that we talk
about a lot is the one I'm about to talk
about but first I have to mention two
things that don't get measured in any of
this first is the fact that sometimes
you have a situation where pharmacists
can't find a job because there's no jobs
available all the pharmacies have the
pharmacists they need so now you've got
this pharmacist who's like teaching
tennis because they can't find a job for
what they were trained in this is called
under employment it's really hard to
measure and quickly the other thing is
that when we measure employment all of
these graphs we're only measuring work
that makes money for the economy there
are millions of people in the US doing
unpaid but highly economically valuable
work mostly caring for people I'm
talking about parents so anyway
underemployment and not paying
caretakers is a whole other topic and I
can make a whole video about that let's
get to the unemployment that we always
hear about in the USA another 2.4
million people have filed for
unemployment benefits in the past week
more than 38 million people have now
lost their job the unemployment that
news anchors and politicians freak out
about looks like this unemployment
numbers are rising this is the worst
crisis they face shock and panics are
the worst layoffs the country has seen
since the Great Depression this is
called cyclical unemployment and it's a
part of that mysterious pattern that we
talked about in the recession video
we're seemingly inevitably and
unpredictably shocks come blowing
through our economy every few years
throwing off the nice balance that
markets are supposed to Trend towards
demand in your industry Falls your
company can no longer afford to pay you
you get fired you're freaked out and
without a paycheck you're not able to
spend money which means that the other
companies are losing revenue and they
have to lay off their people and the
cycle continues and continues the
housing market collapse created One
financial crisis after another this is
cyclical unemployment this cycle is at
the heart of why recessions happen it's
like a dangerous Avalanche of
capitalistic economies and because we
workers are treated like baguettes put
into a market where there's supply and
demand we get hit by this too but
remember that the worst thing that can
happen to a baguette is that it will sit
unsold and uneaten on this Shelf getting
stale I mean you can make some good
croutons out of those I'm not
complaining but humans aren't baguettes
when humans are an unused resource in an
economy that means suffering and misery
and anxiety and worry you didn't do
anything wrong you got your training you
got your job you followed your dreams
the economy even allocated you to a good
fit but now suddenly you're out of work
because everyone around you is losing
income the GDP line is going down and
like I explained in the recession video
when this line goes down in a capitalist
economy bad things happen
foreign
[Music]
Paradox to all of this an economy and a
recession is an economy starving of new
Talent new output and yet during these
spikes when we're in recession all of
the people that could be contributing to
it are sitting idle unable to find a job
in a system that failed them and failed
to coordinate in the worst way possible
ultimately economies exist to help
people Prosper so when an economy
produces all of this misery it's really
failing which is why in a lot of
countries the government has tools to
step in and help both to reduce the
suffering but also to ensure that this
cycle doesn't gain momentum and turn the
whole thing into an anxiety-ridden chaos
which whether we want to think so or not
is an option here economies do collapse
because there is momentum when all of
this anxiety starts to spread and people
stop spending money and people keep
losing their jobs governments often have
to step in and help pump the brakes so
even during the good times the
government will step in and support
unemployed people and during the bad
times unemployment becomes especially
vital for keeping the economy from
collapsing I mean we saw this during
covid unemployment skyrocketed and the
government had to scramble to send us
all money so that we would keep spending
even if we just got fired from our jobs
in Europe and Japan and Korea they did
it a little bit differently they
actually paid the employers to just not
fire people either way the government
did this not only to alleviate the
immediate suffering of the people who
were losing their jobs but also to avoid
the Vicious Cycle unveiled a nearly 2
trillion dollar covid-19 relief plan on
Thursday
urging lawmakers to act fast and jump
start an economy pummeled by the
pandemic
the upshot here is that unemployment is
both complicated and Incredibly high
stakes it's unpredictable we can't
really stop it or at least we haven't
figured out how to yet not only because
it deals with complicated human lives
that have a capacity for suffering but
also because at the end of the day we
humans aren't just participants in the
economy we are the economy in a very
real sense our Mass psychology dictates
how this all plays out and because we
are all tied into this together no
single one of us has total control over
our own situation which is an incredibly
scary thing to think about so don't
think about it too much it's a sort of
Faustian bargain that we've made and for
most of us it's worth it incredible
opportunity for prosperity in exchange
for surrendering some control of our
situation so we do this as one giant
connected group working hard to
coordinate with each other using the
language of prices and wages with the
hope of procuring and providing
resources for ourselves and our family
and this is why politicians and the News
talk about unemployment all the time
it's because our jobs are not baguettes
our work is a huge part of our lives and
yet they are not guaranteed so
supporting jobs job security job
well-being and solid employment truly is
one of the most important things a
government can and should do for its
people okay done
sweet
it's gonna I'm just gonna be a chaotic
man for a second
okay so whoa hi
unemployment hope you understand more
about that topic
ah
[Applause]
moral of the story is that humans aren't
baguettes that's all I was trying to say
okay doesn't mean baguettes aren't
Special Hold on let me finish eating
this Becca
I hope everyone's liking these uh macro
economics explainers there's so many
topics here that are kind of gate kept
by by economists who like to make them
really complicated they're not that
complicated like we can all understand
what this stuff is and yeah I just I
just like the idea of having like a
whole library of macroeconomic Concepts
that we can explain anyway um thanks for
watching today's video and
um thanks to the supporters Over The
Newsroom which is our patreon who
support our videos support our studio
support all the people behind the scenes
we make an extra video for our patrons
every single month and uh it's a behind
the scenes Vlog of how we do what we do
here on
um this YouTube channel that has now
grown into dozens of people who helped
make it possible that that's why we're
able to publish every week not because
of me
I'm one part of it but uh we have a
really cool talented team of people who
help make this possible so that's The
Newsroom we also sell Luts and presets
which help you color your videos and
photos I publish my videos a week early
over on nebula you can see the link in
my description for that and lastly if
there is an economic principle or idea
or thing that you hear a lot about and
want me to explain and unpack just let
me know I am more than happy to keep
this up thank you all for being here
thanks for watching here until the very
end of this video like we're in the last
moments here and you are still watching
which I really appreciate so
um I guess I'll see you with the next
one which is probably going to be soon
or if you go to nebula you could watch
it literally right now but see ya
foreign
[Music]